une personne dans la cinquantaine s'est
présenté dans un hôpital de montréal il
ya quelques jours
souffrant d'un trouble respiratoire
sévère le pôle de soins intensifs pour
quoi que ce soit les symptômes à
observer c'est vraiment de la toux
l'essoufflement des douleurs thoraciques
les autorités de santé publique ont
établi le lien avec le fait que cette
personne va potet depuis quelques mois
son cas ressemble au syndrome qui a
émergé aux états unis dans la dernière
année on peut pas tirer une conclusion
sur un corps actuellement les
l'investigation se fait davantage aux
états unis avec les 800 cas et 12 décès
tous un produit nouveau son l'envoi dans
notre poumon en micro vapeur dans le
fond on avait des préoccupations par
rapport à la direction de santé publique
du québec met donc en place un mécanisme
pour dépister d'autres cas similaires
mais certains vapoteurs n'irons pas
jusqu'à délaisser leur cigarette
électronique pour l'instant que j'étais
mieux de vin poté que d'un seuil
popeline cochonneries comme le skate
non je pense que ça va changer mes
habitudes encore plus qu'il n'ya pas
assez d'études qui sont sortis mais la
nouvelle a de quoi inquiéter aussi ceux
qui vendent des produits devant potage
on va pas un produit dangereux on vend
un produit qui est réglementée
maintenant fédéralement qui nous dit
comment frère le liquide qu'est ce qui
est permis à l'intérieur casque est pas
permis à l'intérieur aux etats unis les
autorités relèvent la piètre qualité des
produits utilisés dans la majorité des
cas dans leur grande majorité des corps
aux états unis ada cd produit trafiqué
avec désuet surtout l'huile de cannabis
pour le cardiologue martin juneau
il est important de bien documenter ce
syndrome respiratoire qui émergent en
amérique avant de bannir le vha potage
les uns que je n'ai acheté légalement
pas c'est interdit ils font deux choses
où ils vont se remettre à fumer qui est
une catastrophe où ils vont sur le
marché noir qui est encore pire selon la
dsp de montréal c'est un produit légal
fabriqués au canada qui serait en cause
dans ce premier cas québécois
ici à nourrice des tati radio canada
montréal